thank you very much to Tibet see Mike
and the organizers for this opportunity
is going to be a tough act following
Michelle but also i will bring in some
different perspectives really even
though I myself also came from the 8tb
community and share with him those
wonderful narrative of the last decade
and the transformation of the global
health space which has attracted so much
attention support leadership and young
interest as well but we are doing
something new and in a way many of you
are already doing it because God systems
has always been part of the country
experience but in the global health
space it has not and what I would like
to do today is talk about this as the
new challenge for global health in a way
compared to the importance and support
that many of the priority disease
programs have enjoyed health system has
been really neglected an orphan in there
so we'll do that building on on the
success of those programs not at the
expense and one point that I think
Michelle the nation is the fact that
among the many shifts in paradigms that
a is brought about and something Miriam
I Kali here nice to emphasize that
there's been a change in the way public
health was about point of service
interventions to really a chronic care
model and that in itself has given great
impetus to the need for a consistent I
must say sorry where am I here I must
say that the science is too young and so
a lot of the things i will mention is
really begin to put together some pieces
of evidence to go beyond the contextual
exceptionalism that although reasonable
has plagued as a problem health systems
is always so local so context all that
we cannot see as a whole we need to a
science can do and and use those
principles then to to guide our
implementation or advocacy and so on but
we need we will need more research so i
hope that i will be
michelle said saying just defined the
need for more research and that many of
you will be helping us answer some of
those questions going forward I may not
have time to leave time for questions
and answers to describe what we are
doing specifically but I think it will
become obvious from the principles that
I hoped articulate a World Health used
to be known as tropical medicine and
there was sort of a Roman Romantic
period of colonial arrangement not so
romantic for for the colonies but
pioneers efforts the missions expressed
in the north coming to eradicate
mosquitoes the early faith on vaccines
all quite linked to colonial linkages
the French with francophone Africa the
bridge with their colonies the u.s. in
America and so on but it was nonetheless
also the beginning of a community of an
emperor of a period where science and
technology could be leveraged to do
better clearly the motivations of most
of the people involved were the right
ones but the envelopes the political
envelope see which has happened were
clearly larger than they are two actors
within the space this change
particularly African Asia given Latin
America's had independence early on with
the end of European colonialism and we
became international health now you have
now 70 or 80 new new countries new
nations new independent member states
with voting rights in the United Nations
in the World Health assemblies
reasserting the serenity and also their
own sense of pride and and destiny a and
that changed everything the change the
dynamics of the work is changed the
dynamics of the role of the countries
and a gun of course starting the wave
over 50 years ago in but II don't use
also was taking place in the context of
the Cold War and there was this divide
in the Cold War politically economically
conceptually a and it was also time
because of that of international
solidarity there was war but a social
solidarity and health was a political
balloon people will play with health and
if you can read the deliberations in the
US Congress about how important
politically it was to do health because
the soul
seems to have a better hand at it
because in this era of international
health he was about health he was not
medicine tropical medicine international
health health was too because true
socially was community-based this was
the time where primary health care for
all and the AL Mata conference could
take place and it was a tricky period
and leadership of EE show a mother of
the mother was very carefully in walk in
this tight line between in the Cold War
forces indeed the United States was on
his knees in the 70s if you recall with
a similar economic crisis oil prices
spike in the Watergate scandal the
Vietnam mess was a bad time so the
Soviets were you know gaining the upper
hand on the PR of the times and it was
in that context that the Alma the
conference takes place and mother wanted
the conference to take place in a
non-aligned country they want to mess up
with the politics of the Cold War and he
thought of Egypt and yet Egypt was just
signing up the Camp David agreements
which pretty much turned him into a
pariah in the Muslim community in the
Arab world so nobody will show up even
in the rest of the debris show work in
their offices for a couple of years so
that was out and the soviet russia kept
insisting in paying for the whole
conference he was a Soviet Republican so
now that was so and in 78 this happened
as he happened the United States had no
delegation to do almohada hey although a
senator Kennedy was there sitting next
to mother in his personal capacity and
but the Chinese but the US was not there
officially the Chinese did not go either
admission is had as many credentials as
the Soviets in socialism and primary
care with the Burford doctors they were
just in a hot war in the North East with
Russia and about invasion now which was
a soviet supported country so it was a
difficult period the Chinese not showing
up also was a problem so there were many
politics on what otherwise is a pristine
beacon of Public Health al mata and
primary health and here for all
and that was a problem he remains a
vehicle for many of us in public health
but it was already at Birth politicize
and that political dimensions took a
prize with the end of the Cold War when
we became global health with the end of
the Cold War Reagan was now the priest
the high priest of the period and Reagan
Frost's the budget of the ratio I remain
frost and frozen until years the last
administration so for over 20 years the
core budget of the ratio was not
increased leveraging the high proportion
of the body the US had and well that's
how it works out and it was in
parramatta in part the alignment with
with the cold war era and so many other
things obviously as well involved but it
was the case and it was a sad period
there was almost like a hangover first
in the eighties and that was difficult
very difficult for the community for
global health in general and yet global
health began to brew there because other
forces were a play with the end of the
Cold War a globalization trade markets
IDs NGOs it was the time where markets
and NGOs could supply all of the
services require who needed government
was the question of the time and go to
the word supposed to shrink forever and
then the World Bank reforms at the time
pretty much made that also effective and
it was a difficult period again in that
sense but things began to happen in a
different way and you have now new
philanthropies new funds and many public
private partnerships and the Rockefeller
Foundation was very much involved in
setting up many of those partnerships
first around R&D and bob is here from
the International is vaccine initiative
TB drug development dengue vaccine new
medicines malaria there was a new model
w show was going crazy in the beginning
not knowing what was happening what to
do but it was a new world the world had
changed and all these public-private
partnerships were now happening for good
reason and but also in the political
sense they could not have happened I
believe in the 1970s in the middle of
the Cold War where public and private
were polarized
they were possible in this new
globalized era and likewise i believe
almada may not have been possible in the
90s so the political economy matters and
things do change and I believe we are
now heading for another big change and
this is just a hypothesis a speculation
for for us all I believe the meltdown of
the market last year changes things
dramatically and I believe in Marcus I
believe in profits I am NOT against that
the Rockefeller Foundation was based on
both a but I believe these will change
again the space in which we do our work
in this sort of a pendulum right
tropical medicine was technical more
vertical priorities of education then
international health was more horizontal
I don't believe in horizontal some
verticals I believe in the hole but the
tom was clear then global hell became
again priority disease technology
solutions and expertise and so on I
believe this is changing again and a
first the financial crisis itself a
alighted 70s and 80s where they were
inflationary and colleague for fiscal
disciplines tightening of social
spending and all of that this one
actually has frozen the financial flows
and credit market so that the this type
of crisis has been calling for a
stimulus in and we've seen a lot of
stimulus in so it's a different crisis
in that sense but it's also a very
profound crisis obviously and is not one
that simply effects budget or concerns
for subsequent funding it is a crisis
that has a potential to catalyze
analogically the political will to
transform Social Protection health
systems in particular and most of the
examples or universal health coverage in
the world happened not out of rational
advocacy but out of crisis and it was
crisis that trigger the opportunity and
the things then happened he but more
profoundly I believe this is going to
change the political economy too and the
dependent will shift I believe back to
national governments and that will
change how we work and what we can do
and where we cannot do that easily
and this is what we I think we'll see in
the next five years in another five or
ten the markers will be up and running
again and and everything will begin to
move back in the other direction but i
believe the pendulum of history we have
this taste and even the united states
where until recently the federal
government was supposed to shrink in the
social space cities and states were
supposed to do it who needed the federal
government and of course now series and
garmin sun on their knees and really
depending on the national government
this is not only happening the united
states is actually happening around the
world and so the strengthen the other
hand of garments means a lot for the
type of work we might do in the next
decade this past decade or was
phenomenal as michelle pointed out the
spending went from barely three billion
dollars in global health nearly now 17
billion and so hopefully reaching 20
billion in the future so a lot of money
has gone into health quite a success
story in so many ways and yet as you
also know the challenge has not totally
gone away there's been a lot of success
and we have to acknowledge the
improvements in infant mortality in aids
tuberculosis infection rates probably
going down after first time in history
so all of many good things actually
happening but there are still nearly 10
million kids dying every year mostly
from things for which we have solutions
and or over a half a million women dying
because they're giving birth and so
these are things for which the health
system as a whole is an indicator of
this functionality and for which select
interventions might be helpful and
there's still plenty of room there but
we certainly should be also thinking of
the whole it is the case that MDGs will
not be achieved unless we address health
systems as a whole and the map also
shows of course where those kids are
dying mainly the poor countries soon
saharan africa and south south southeast
asia it is important though because the
previous lights most of that money i
tell you eighty percent of the u.s.
funding internationally inhale
is for HIV and they should be
responsible for only three percent of
these deaths so we need more for the
priority programs but we also need more
for the rest and how to get that balance
is of course a challenge that the
countries themselves leave every every
day the challenge that we we see is at
the chorus health systems but they're
more general as I heard in the previous
questions and answer session access how
do we have access to all of the other
conditions people come with complaints
on Daria pneumonia and rash fever a
quality which has been considered luxury
we don't know you'd have to measure well
in a system today in Africa a but also
involves safety patient safety mistakes
and things that will to pay attention
dignity I mean I can't remake
controlling if you Demi bike by locking
up all of the people at risk and that's
not necessarily they're the best way
really in in today's world and
affordability there is clearly one of
the issues that moved us and is is the
money in the health system and and we'll
talk about that clearly there's a high
out-of-pocket expenditures in publishing
Couture of expenses and no health
insurance really to speak of when Obama
Hillary were debating in the primaries
about how they will remain committed to
fighting aids and other diseases in
Africa I was telling my wife maybe in
the next election they will talk about
how every every human being should have
coverage health insurance I mean why
only five percent of our because you
have health insurance health coverage we
worry about the fifteen percent of
Americans without it but we don't even
realize that ninety-five percent of the
people in Africa do not have it and what
does this mean it is not about their
salads giving more money to them by
insurance for all of the people in
Africa it is just the result of what i
believe is is bad but stewardship of the
system in this life from the bank as you
can see low-income countries most of
their spending is private out-of-pocket
a little bit of insurance and then the
gorram
including a lot of the ODA that we spoke
of before buried in in the in the public
budget that that means that the health
spending in low-income countries is that
people's own money is not foreign aid is
the people's own money and is being
spent in the worst form possible this is
inefficient and regressive the poor are
hit the wars and so a hundred fifty
million people every year end up
spending nearly half of their annual
income in health we were doing health we
doctors don't like to term within first
do not harm but in providing services we
actually hurting people 25 million
families who are no longer poor every
year bumper because of health spending
in this country sixty-two percent of the
bankruptcies before this crisis is
housing crisis sixty-two percent is due
to health bills and so clearly a as
countries developed you can see how
things become more rational it is not so
much that the good that it has to be a
gorman driven system but the financing
and the stewardship clearly the
government matters and this is simply
how it happens in the world today and so
and that happened though I must point
out that the service provision become
more private that is the poor countries
have a mostly out of pocket private
financing and some government service
provision but that changed and the
private sector becomes more and more
involved in the provision yes as calm as
we call more amore involved in indie
financing lots of things here and this
is light also from from the bank showing
how people pay for things and most of
them spend their incomes as a safe for
or sell their a borrow from family or
sell the house or sell the cow a is a
mess is quite bad and is happening every
every year now here and this may be a
beautiful of a stretch a but i would
like to position early on the importance
of universal coverage as the new
frontier
for global health this is the first map
actually I've seen on universal health
coverage and it is based on data from
the international labor organizations
report on social probation for help from
last year which uses a definition of
universal coverage that allows the
United States and South Africa to appear
as if they had universal coverage in the
sense that many of us may share and that
is it is the case that in this country
if you're sick you can go to Mercy room
and by law you will be taken care of but
we know that does not how it works right
start sending your bills and does not
follow up so but because it too sure you
have the right to health and in that
formal definition the u.s. and South
Africa may look all right but
importantly these these maps which I
believe universal health coverage is the
right thing both economically I will
speak to that but also as a human right
it's also feasible and because nearly 50
countries already have universal health
coverage which again is both about
reorganizing service provision and
access but also the financial protection
that that a whole system can can
organize and it is beginning to happen
sorry in the world it's also clear of
course that it is precisely in africa
and south of the station when all those
children were dying that we don't even
know whether there's coverage with and
even we cannot even tell today so and
and yet at the same time there are few
countries already moving in Latin
America there is an old tradition of
Social Protection and our colleagues
from Mexico here where I am from by the
way may speak more about the experience
of progress to universal coverage in
Mexico Thailand has been an example of
providers who have coverage the country
that is not rich and there are many
other examples and we hope to talk more
from our College from Ghana and run that
I have already moved into the path of
universal coverage challenging as it is
but believe me it is the right thing as
I would show also in a second if we can
follow the money we can find a few
things first that
health spending spending money on health
offers many many instance some of them
are actually counterintuitive and i
would like to provoke you with some of
those data and some speculation clearly
they the commissioners on omega
convincing health in two thousand oratio
make clear the need to put more money in
health and we will try to make the case
here that there's more to it than that
we also believe now financing is the
control knob of the health system that
policymakers can use and so it's
important that we pay attention to that
and it's also crucial to really address
the incentive structures that grantees
access respiration and so on now some
yes so people have read the book of his
lame but I mean I am NOT an economist
I'm a physician and Redeemer ologies so
on but nonetheless many of our
colleagues share some views that there's
some have a right level of health
spending in English poor countries don't
have enough and we need to help just
reach that basic right level and the
rich countries like the United States
are spending just too much and we need
to rein in costs so we have a normative
sense of some middle about right amount
of spending we also think that with more
than cost-effective iterations happening
progressively we should wipe our disease
and in fact burden of disease is coming
down all over the world and even the
chronic diseases new states cancer
stroke and vascular disease is coming
down so we will think that as people
gross healthier Asia gas that health
spending should be declining but none of
these halls as you may know first in
this light with plots GDP against
childhood mortality as like the many you
are familiar with chose the obvious that
richer countries have less mortality
among their kids but there are a couple
of interesting things here right so poor
people the words as a there's a sad
reality today that
importantly they are the correlation of
these two parameters is very very middle
of the road fifty-eight percent and so
there's a lot of variation here and GDP
already is highly correlated and
accounts for water sanitation fertility
rates literacy rates and so why do
countries in the same region with the
same i shall be levels do so differently
why what is it that they are doing
different with the same money they are
delivering much better health a concept
of good health ilocos that 25 years ago
the Rockefeller studied and show that
countries like Cuba costa rica que ella
Sri Lanka China were doing quite well
despite very low amount of health
spending and today we have a lot more
data more systematic data and we
actually revisiting the good health a
local studies and their new with
performers whether it's Vietnam eritrea
a countries that can do well I mean
china has move out of because I have
more money now than they used to in
these quadrants but we are now studying
why why do you see that those health
systems do differently that leads to
better outcomes five can fall out
because with the same money certainly
work learning more about that and I hope
that many of you will have a study and
it's also clear that even as you keep
spending more and more and more you
don't do so much after that so that you
know money matters but it's not all
about money and as Professor ramalinga
so I mean in India used to say yes we
need more more money for help but we
also need more help for the money I
think who do prolly always size that
line if he was here before it but we
don't know how to do this and those are
the tough questions you were asking a
many tough questions a what are you
doing an economy that is informal
there's no tax base to reorganize
financing he how do you do it when you
have we capacity to manage the private
sector which have been concealed outside
of your other government system for too
long and even though it's fifty to
eighty percent of the sector as a whole
a how do you
but insurance to the rural poor digital
areas these are all the real challenges
that some of you who are already engaged
in this space are probably facing and
you can share a lot more and again he
these questions require analysis and
learning but also politically that you
clearly challenges a compulsion
everybody has to be in the pool
cross-subsidization the rich to the poor
the healthy to the sake and some Russian
not everything will be covered in any
health system and so these are going to
be political challenges for every
society as we really grapple with health
now in this slide in which GDP and total
health spending are plotted for the
first time this decade we have data on
all most countries from most of the last
half century we only have they done OECD
countries but now we can look at all of
the countries around the world and find
similar things that we have learned in
OECD countries before but I haven't
percolated the minds of our global
health community yet these light shows
of course a strong correlation between
GDP and health spending that is rich
countries spend more in health and that
is so obvious so common sense you can so
self-evident that it has to secure to
other parameters in this in this plot
the first is the correlation of these
two parameters 95% correlations are very
hard to find in the real world as you
know if those who do research especially
in the social space such high
correlation means that we need nothing
else really we don't need any other
predatory variable at least if you give
me the GDP of a country we can tell you
how much the country spends in health in
total and it also means at least from
this ecological cross-sectional data set
that there's little room for Policy
maneuvering that is the idea that poor
countries can increase their spending or
the rich countries can decrease the
spending and sort of filled the line
doesn't seem to be the case the data
suggests that there is a deterministic
path which the Economist in the OECD
countries since the 70s have called the
first law healthy
nomics there's no good reason really
well there are some reasons but but for
this tight correlation is still almost
almost mystical in so it hurts a lot of
attention because he has lots of
implications for for each of you and our
work and importantly when you add to
these regression the proportion of the
total spending that is public which as I
said in Africa is 50% in AJ's twenty
percent it doesn't matter it has nothing
to the regression that is if countries
and this data has been analyzed by
Jack's vantika who was the bank and the
enough economics an observable
University if a government was to
increase public spending private
spending out of pocket will decrease and
the total will still fall on the line if
the governments of the opposite and try
to decrease your spending by decreasing
the public budget the opposite happened
and the total falls on the line it's
really amazing because people out of
pocket finishes are so independent
random almost and how when you go back
and do household surveys a year later
and as much people spend how does this
aggregate falls guided by an invisible
hand on the line and this applies a
countries who may have a universal
health systems like Canada or the UK or
countries in which the financing is
private eighty-three percent like India
or Vietnam and they follow the line it
applies also to Eritrea one of the
countries with the highest proportion of
the public budget goes into defense they
also follow the line and so that's Costa
Rica with no army and we always thought
if that government was not buying that
summary we could be by so many much more
vaccines well the data doesn't seem to
back that up in and again this is just
ecologic cross-sectional data we need to
do a lot more research more sensitively
perhaps is the second point and Michelle
is gone so I can made a point here but
exactly it more than a point is really a
question for all of us it's just too
important a question Michelle gia said
that there is no evidence that spending
in aids crowds out spending and to me
that is the problem how come we spent 20
billion dollars a year and we don't know
if we are crowding out spending in poor
countries actually the preliminary
analysis that we have done on this the
jack has done on this again the data is
thinner here okay first because because
as you know all da accounts for just
barely five percent of the Lord
middle-income countries can spend which
is a small proportion compared to public
which is not fifty percent of the
spending so smaller data that there is
probably more difficult it is the case
that a third of the a das hangs out the
international consultants another third
two minutes of Fighters uses for foreign
reserves and all your therapy reaches
the center of the ground but still the
analysis that Jax has done and he might
try to publish is shows that crowding
out is seems to be a place that is that
the health spending is a fungible space
if a country spending a hundred million
dollars he held not only the public and
private components matters they say
before little but if you were to add
another twenty million dollar sort of
your philanthropy heart you will expect
120 but that should show up here and we
have a few things but in North Korea if
people have familiar with a Gapminder we
have now plotted this data into cam mind
if so you can see the flow over time and
North Korea that goes crazy so I'm sure
maybe that data is not a very reliable
one but it's clear that the data
suggests that the money pushes out
spending and if you are almost fifty
percent of the spending is for HIV and
only three percent of the population
have HIV it's okay to get money for HIV
but if actually pushing out spending on
other basic things through this mystical
invisible hand that deserves all of our
research attention then we have a
problem a big problem and and it's
something that a lack of evidence of the
problem is not evidence of his absence
and it's something that requires a lot
more attention and I think Miriam
has been looking at this and Jack will
be in the international conference in
Cape Town and there will be a session
just on this issue and next year in
Vienna for the major international
conference there will be a whole
parallel track now on health systems
health policy health economics these are
two important questions to simply not
not answer them now this is the same
data I'm cheating a little bit here
because I make this into a log scale
that of course curves the line but it's
actually honest because the point I'm
trying to make is true that is the
increasing health spending with GDP that
the data suggests here is not a
one-to-one relationship exactly a
one-on-one 21.2 lock relationship that
is for every ten percent increase in GDP
health spending growth eleven twelve
percent compounded and so this is what
we happening around us everywhere we've
been talking a lot about in the United
States and all the other countries we
have lower GDP have always been so
behind so they're always compared to
United States being low but the fact is
health spending is growing is growing
fast is not because of abuja declaration
commitments is not because of the OTA is
the country's own money growing as their
economies developed in the last 20 years
quite a dramatic transformation that we
are calling the economic transition of
health and is not subject to policy
really is not a very twisted or decrease
it is it is just it's almost a
deterministic path and more
understanding of that is again an area
that deserves more research in and that
we are very much interested in in
studying and supporting so this is the
reality and the US Steel is out of whack
and so in many of the oil countries seem
to be spending less but on the whole
everybody seems to be on the line and
said they r square is ninety-five
percent so quite an incredible
correlation and the same thing is the
poorer countries where you come down
come down the line so this is quite
dramatic is out there is happening but
we don't get to see it we've been busy
fighting a CD
and yet this is so important right now
especially we're going to have a
rational system that provides access and
quality and affordability now this is
slightly shows GDP growth as you can see
the gdp in the world was relatively fat
for most of the history even though the
British were in the dust revolution but
for the world was a tiny bit compared to
the fighter child I mean they were not
moving and so on but it's after World
War two the GDP takes off the United
States was leading the charge then the
Europeans in the sixties and the
Japanese in the 70s and as you know now
everybody's being growing despite this
particular year of recessions growth is
being really taking place dramatically I
haven't been able but maybe we should
you have to now put here total health
spending growing 1.1 1.2 log compound on
the back of that growth in GDP so the
world spending today nearly six trillion
dollars in health and a lot of that
money's american dollars of course where
is already eighteen seventeen eighteen
percent of the gdp but health spending
is growing this is the US and we've been
seeing it and complaining and trying to
bring it down we haven't been very
successful here now china in the last 25
years China health spending real not
twice not ten times not 20 times i gue
50 times and the government was trying
to increase her spending in the top is
the government spending but the gdp
growth of China was calling for more it
was like this God who was calling for
more spending because the gdp was
growing so as a default most of the
spending in China was occurring in the
private sector out-of-pocket fee for
services under the table all of that so
China has now a Messier system than they
used to 50 years ago and that's very sad
even though they're spending 50 times
more and now the Chinese are now
understanding this and they are now
committing to universal health coverage
and they are convenient to almost
doubling their the public expenditure on
these my prediction is that that is
going to fall short
still and that and again there will be
sealed problems but it's a great sign
already that there's an assertion of
direction for vision is this is GDP
growth over years and as you can see
Susan Africa has been growing faster
than the world average and faster than
the oecd countries clearly so Africa's
GDP has been growing fast so if we
simply apply the projections from the
regulations that with right before
simplest projection speculation based on
is the World Bank expected and actually
is the IMF and also the projections for
the Goldman Sachs and others offer for
gdp growth we can predict the next
decade health spending will double or
triple in many of the countries we are
working with now and again it has been
growing already population has been
growing and so does that eats out Uganda
for example is a problem still but here
spending is going to be growing in this
in this country's and this is both the
challenges but I am an optimist I see
this an incredible opportunity for
health and for health system now this is
in the United States this is projections
by the Congressional Budget Office which
are a very authoritative respected
office in the US government Congress and
they show here that health spending
today accounts for about fifteen sixteen
percent of the gdp and before the center
is over it will consume half of the GDP
of this country now this is a projection
of the Congressional Budget Office may
be wrong but this is what they are
telling the Congress they see happening
this is amazing and interestingly is not
aging we thought it was because people
were getting old in the demand for
services was growing aging is really a
small slice of this growth in ambassador
Tom Poquette recently with Eastern
medicine report when we discuss this is
but how are we going to afford to pay
for that
and I and the answer is it is because we
will afford it that it will happen in
fact is because we've been affording it
year after years that he's been growing
if you make a hundred thousand dollar
salary and pay ten thousand dollars in
health premiums health insurance
premiums you wouldn't like to increase
that to 30,000 right who would tripling
of your health premiums but if your
salary goes up just by 50% to 150 the
30,000 still twenty percent versus ten
percent before leaves you with 130
thousand dollars to spare whereas before
you have 90 even if you account for some
inflation there and this has been
happening in America year after year
year after year and instead of embracing
the growth we've been trying to fight
the growth and i will post you but
that's actually the wrong way to address
this economic transition it was not
aging actually i was saying if many of
you are familiar with this a report will
fang and others looking at what matters
in health and access to health care
three accounts for ten percent of the
gains in health most is in the biology
behaviors the environment so how come if
this is the only tonya if the health
system health care system i guess for
such small part of the health system
health the decal style population how
come we are spending more and more and
more and more and more and I actually
kind of speculated as burden of disease
goes down if we can assume that there
will always be bugs changing and so on
but if I at the end of this century we
were to eliminate this is as we have
known in history shall spend it will not
go down and people are shifting from
buying life and of course they're still
a lot of life to save but there is
achieved them from buying life to buying
quality and there is an insatiable
appetite as economics develop to buy
wellness and quality of health and so
this is happening one explanation of
course
is demand of the population in so many
ways but why does he happen this way is
economies William bomber from prison who
figured this out and I am a believer in
his principles but there are other
economists who who still challenge
moments tenants but basically vamos says
health spending increasing is not a
result of increasing demand for services
or the increase the supply of expensive
technologies everything matters but
they're small the reason for increased
spending is the differential in
productivity across sectors in the
economy when other sectors in the
economy as we have been witnessing for
most of the century grow in productivity
whether it's in agriculture with 20 fold
gains in productivity and that's a
commercial reduction in price of food
whether it's in manufacturing whether it
is in distribution in telecommunications
efficiency gains there means that the
products and services will be cheaper
and by default the inflation of the
sectors that lag in productivity gain
will be greater than average and so
sectors that cannot substitute labor
capital for labor but is that cannot be
automated so that with money you can get
things done without people doing the job
like health where we want doctors and
nurses we don't want just a computer
although we believe in computers for
health till in that that condemns health
education the Performing Arts to have
inflation greater than average and and
again it seems that as GDP growth
because of productivity gains then you
can expect to see a predictable increase
in health spending for the foreseeable
future in in most countries there has to
be at some point some ending of this
paradigm but we had not seen it really
in the last 50 years in this country in
most of the OECD countries and we
believe most of developing countries
will be having more of that what that
means is this phenomena arouses outside
the hell market
traditional cost control does not
decrease total spending I mean there's
no country that I am aware that has been
able to decrease total health spending
as the GDP is growing and actually when
you try to control costs out of policy
you end up destroying the system and I
think the United States is probably the
best example of that I will come back to
that in a second now this is a
macroeconomist view of the world in
which okay arisia countries to spend
more a and even more so than the GDP
growth in fact that is the very
definition of a luxury in economists
term that is when you're spending is
something grows faster than your income
that's a luxury but actually at the
micro level in households the opposite
is true poorer households spend a
greater proportion of the incoming
health than Richard households and so
these two worlds exist they both coexist
they're both truth and they've been
studied extensively they and they
collide they collide particularly so
when GDP grows and so many of the
countries that are now beginning to
develop economically there's be many we
talked about bricks but as I said
African countries are growing just as
fast as many of those other countries
from a smaller economy start point but
growing nonetheless just as fast you
create a collision in which as the
government's the country's get richer
but not everybody in the country gets
richer the poor people will be facing a
growing inflation in health services and
you can predict a way which W is now
documenting of catastrophic expenditure
all over the world particularly in those
transitional economies in and this is
predictable unless there is social
protection or insurance we should say
before that is the problem we don't have
for most of the poor countries we
talking about and when we talk about
universal insurance then is not about
adding more money to then get it but
reorganizing what is now primitive
out-of-pocket spending sure
into more rational prepaid risk pooling
my understand Bob will tell you more
about that tomorrow the United States I
mentioned before this is an example of
this paradigm in 1990 GDP health
spending about 700 billion population
forty percent without health insurance
in America we said then that we couldn't
afford to cover them in sure because
scoffs timing has been growing so much
we believe that there is a logical trade
of between a coverage and costs and then
unless we control cause we cannot afford
to cover everybody that's quite logical
but in my view of the world sexually a
fallacy because what happens is health
spending growth anyway because GDP has
been growing even though policymakers
have been trying we invented managed
care we invented diagnostic related
group through Hospital compensation we
keep trying to decrease Medicare
reimbursement for primary care every
year and a health spending keeps growing
as the GDP growth and so we end up with
a large gdp in America in 2006 and are
greater chunk of that going into health
spending so that we are spending three
times three times as much as we were
standing before and now the population
which has grows we have sixteen percent
of the Americans without insurance so
we're spending three times more but we
did not invest that growth in doing the
right things and by default the money
gets spent in all sort of wrong things
from waist to really blown out profits
because how else can you have a new drug
good as they might be serious I'm is one
example going for five hundred thousand
dollars a year I mean pricing is not the
result of course is the result of what
the market can observe and this is an
example from severe popular Mexico and
our colleagues may expand on this this
is GD P versus total health spending in
Mexico over the year so this alone
another example where they r square
still hold high correlation even in a in
one country longitudinally and this
applies to almost all of the countries
that we were looking at in 1994 Mexico
her and economic crisis and so we went
to a somersault in GDP and in health
spending but then the kind of economy
recover and growth continued and health
spending continues to grow with it and
this is when when Julio Frank arrives in
a new democratically elected government
in mexico in two thousand and of course
the normal response is well you your
spending has been increasing we r cosine
of control same thing and normally the
instruction of the mr. finances you have
to cut the cost or maybe just allow for
some inflation instead let the
leadership of julio and i think it was
very important is using evidence but
also ethical arguments and the political
space the democracy brought convince the
government of Mexico to commit to cover
the forty percent of mexicans who were
poor unemployed or informal employed who
did not have any coverage and to commit
to cover them to this seguro popular
popular health insurance and in doing so
nonetheless it was not something to be
done overnight is not something that we
was very very astute politically and
materially it was something that was
going to take place over a decade really
in it also it will not going to take
anything from anybody else that is the
other bodies will the sacred crowds will
not going to be touched and so that you
know this spending has to be additional
spending if you can figure it out but of
course if you can read this data
carefully the future can be figured out
so health spending went up and
seventy-five percent of the federal
spending growth was for this new program
in Mexico and the important thing is
that health spending has grown but so
had the GDP of Mexico and actually the
health spending falls exactly on the
line predicted by the GDP and the
question is if Mexico had not committed
to progressively standing you
universal coverage maybe maybe I believe
quite so they will still haven't spent
as much but they would still have forty
percent of the people without insurance
and this is the paradigm that requires
your thinking and research in your own
countries because it changes the
argument as to how we going to finance
health in the fusion again it will not
be foreign aid is going to be domestic
financing itself many policy
implications I would say do not fight
the transition embrace it simply try to
control costs is will not happen and
this may be more relevant of course to
those transitional economies he may be
the poorest countries we still need to
invest and help plan ahead so plan for
that future of growth and investing
equity and quality of the health system
do get more bang for the buck we know
that performance matters and that more
can be done with the same money so as
the money is growing there will be more
money for health but we also need to get
more health for the money we need more
research no doubt clearly this an area I
don't want to convince you that is an
academic dream we don't have enough
publications to understand this and
education for a global community and our
national health communities this is
spending around the globe as with these
guys before and this is the slice that
goes into health systems a small slice
most of that as we heard is to train
doctors and nurses not to figure out the
stewardship and the financing of your
health system and dr. nurses matter
especially you needed to provide enter
two mile treatment but it's not the only
part of the solution and as you can see
many of the katas are here they are
spending some of them more in health
systems and a city for in some of those
countries things are beginning to happen
Rhonda is now increasing their spending
as well and rather has been very good
with their mood 12 systems to also
leverage blow more fun to subsidize the
premiums of the poor and those will a
shabby infection so great experiences I
think that we can hear more from Ghana
and ran in particular impressive how
India
that is pretty much a private mess
everything is eighty-four percent of the
spending is private in India and whereas
in China they can commit to universal
coverage and you can expect that to
happen in India is more complicated that
they just got going with a community
universal coverage and it's quite
impressive yes in one year which is
moving very fast and part of that was
the election hopefully now after
direction that we continue to commit to
this this social circle transformation
very interesting and back to the
research part we are investing little on
health systems to think in the capacity
but also the knowledge in the United
States the world spends 150 billion
dollars in health research every year
two-thirds of that is American money and
in the US this is the landscape pharma
spends the most in R&D for product from
surgical products the in aviation
biomedicine spends a lot of money too
and this is the American agency for
health research and quality that is in
charge of health systems research most
Americans have never heard of thee if
they have heard of the Global Fund they
have not heard of this agency and maybe
there is not work they're spending one
dollar per capita in researching the
health system that consumes seven
thousand dollars plus per capita clearly
is the lowest investment in R&D of any
enterprise that I know of even as the
money is growing so much so it's good to
hear that President Obama is committing
a cost cost effectiveness that will be
part of the equation but it's more than
cost effectiveness as you can see that
we need to mind so we need to increase
that and I'm happy to see that from the
stimulus package actually a this budget
went up for for health services went up
almost three or fourfold versus the
irrigation went up just steal our money
but only a third so this needs to happen
there's been global attention we are
almost finished here we started at a
rockefeller with a political meeting
just upstate with a state of the family
the Rockefeller family and we post the
global challenge of health systems to a
series of global leaders and we started
the conversation and getting it going
lots of be happening we have a
commitment to health systems to capacity
to stewardship to the private sector
awareness a span of the stewardship of
garments we also care for each elf and
we had a large years of conference we
CIT as the technology of health systems
of the future that can help improve
access affordability and quality of
health services and we've been
supporting several processes and
meetings high-level meetings with the US
Secretary General the first of that was
in october two thousand seven where the
Secretary General has committed to
global health as one of the priorities
for his administration follow up with a
meeting with the President Jimmy Carter
hosted in Atlanta with the elders and
the Secretary General where commitments
were made to health systems maternal
mortality and the most neglected
diseases as the three areas that this
new movement was going to support and we
just met yesterday the UN Michelle and
many others and this was now not a small
meeting but it was really the plenum of
the UN with all other delegations
ambassadors on discussing global health
health systems maternal health and it's
been incredible because we witnessed
some of that in the 8th movement which
was incredible of a song her sisters we
didn't expect to move up that fast at
the highest levels of policy in part
because I'm worried that we haven't yet
mobilize the community and there's a lot
of work to be done there civil society
and another's to move the g8 summit we
supported the Technical Working Group
that the Kami group or health systems
that led to a declaration in the g8 of a
balance between the priority programs
and the health systems going forward we
working with italians to continue to
advance this again that makes year the
g8 will be hosted by the Canadians who
do not need any advocacy in terms of
health systems and universal coverage
and so lots of coordinated the
ministerial conference in Bamako and
opportunity to call for more research in
this area and there will be a symposium
on research for universal coverage next
year global symposium there's a report
into the medicine that also includes
health system now this is the meetings
were referring to there will be more
follow-up in the economic the echo
subgroup of the UN we had a conversation
with several stakeholders
man in the world of assembly on
transforming health systems for
universal health coverage the g8 next
year the ratio has decided to the theme
for the worker report will be universal
health coverage so clearly the
discussion is now alive in but we still
need a lot more research we still need a
lower capacity we need more resources
for this to happen and even though we
believe is more about reorganizing the
financing of domestic resources are
supposed to throw any more aid there is
a cost in building the capacity and
managing the change and that cost is the
responsibility of the international
community and it's a course that we
haven't yet costed but it's something
that I love this meeting process that
may be a global transfers on universal
health coverage will begin to address so
as a way of summarizing total spending
is growing fast developed by driven by
economic development during the last 20
years this is a fact in in most
low-income countries this growth is
happening in the private sector and it
is out of pocket which is as I said
before inefficient regressive accounts
for fifty to eighty percent of the total
health spending in Africa and Asia
compared to barely ten percent in the
richer countries and its leading to a
wave of catastrophic expenditures that
will only grow in the next decade
without national stewardship this will
happen by default in we have a lot of
mess happening around the world unless
we also have that Russians to worship
and prepaid risk pool system because
otherwise financial risk will grow is
this of the shift from saving life again
to saving buying wellness but if you
think of the cartoon of is your life or
your money and the health systems will
increasingly be about quality and the
money the solution is less about
additional Oda and is about organizing
the financing and universal health
coverage which
about the health systems when it works
when the health system words you have
universal coverage which is universal
access to appropriate health services
and affordability for the individuals in
in the system and this is a challenge
and opportunity that requires both
greater leadership and capacity at the
national level but also international
support and I look forward to working
with you in the space thank you as we
have time we thought we were just you
know take 10 10 minutes or so with their
questions in the audience you're all
hungry hey my name is and not a nun from
the Gates Foundation in Seattle and I'm
always fascinated by seeing the
difference in the statistic you showed
up the seven hundred million dollars we
spend on health it's now two point one
trillion and we claim to not be able to
afford the uninsured and in my mind the
questions not so much are we spending on
those people we are spending on those
people it's the question of how do we
spend for everybody and for what
services do we spend and I wonder if
there's a opportunity to shift the and
maybe it's already taking place in the
vocabulary being used in the policy
world where it's not just about health
insurance per se because by definition
insurance about pooling resources to
cover unwanted unexpected events not
about getting the everyday vaccines
every day well checks etc and so how do
we as a community begin to shift the
vocabulary needed to really have
policymakers understand it's not about
health care reform about health reform
Thanks good questions the British don't
like the word insurance by the way they
always think is American private and a
and so I guess out of the the World
Health Assembly coined and if you've
been in some of those meetings
discussions on terminology and right of
resolutions when they came up with a
with a warning of universal health
coverage we reflected a lot of those
constraints and compromises in all the
definitions are important in DNA's
bringing education and clarity and then
action but I agree that a there you're
also hinted and another point which is
that there are different segments of
financing of health services that is it
is not the same to provide the basic
preventive interventions we should be
free for everybody really and point to
service and does that is compare that
with the space of risk of people who may
or may not get a heart attack and may or
may not get a is is the rare event which
is the insurance typically applies for
and there are others who they have
chronic conditions and they are now
going to be having requirements of
services going on forever and then
there's the end of life which society
can make many choices to how what we
cover how we finance that so each of
those spaces are different and different
societies address and differently
although again we have not been very
explicit in the compared assistance
analysis to see what what is probably
useful in the end there will be no
cookie cutters whether it is on the
financing or on the service provision
models because there will be social
preferences and resources and burden
priorities and so on that that will
still have a lot of room for this but I
agree that there is no single space and
the terminology may be confusing the
people they speak of social health
insurance which is like one of the
German model of employer base the
premiums payments or the British
Canadians which are more tax base
systems more general pools of resources
and so a maybe care for example is not
really a pool is like going in and out
every hair right so yeah there are many
models for the pooling and I think
tomorrow will be here more from up on
financing pool
Thanks it from your experience
especially in Mexico what are we have to
do for innovation in value or what are
we what are the opportunity areas in the
suguru public Thanks I mean I I could
ask you the question but we we had an
interest and think the Gates Foundation
also on the road the private sector in
health but because of the magnitude and
the neglect and the ideological sparks
but also because there's a lot of
innovation taking place and we have been
landscaping around the world loss of
innovations that the private sector is
doing even though there are
profit-driven market mechanisms that
provide services for the poor in there
is a lot of ideas from from social
franchising to vouchers to conditional
cash transfers that the Mexico has also
led in and that is being using many
other countries mature mortality was
discussed of the UN and so if in India
for example there's new a new program
and you you pay the mother to go and
have the baby in the facility and that
gives the young mother leverage over the
mother-in-law who will say way we have
12 and you know we're okay why do you
have to go it must come out right and so
the fact that the service will be
covered by a conditional cash transfer
mechanism if leverage to young wives
spouses and so on to be able to sue
there's a lot of those and I think that
a cataloguing that innovation is one
thing that we need to do i chair we
don't have a policy community to share
this and this is one of the things we
are very much interested in a recent
meeting where we heard the spirits of
Ghana experience of Thailand and
experience of India is clear that
there's a lot happening it doesn't get
published and that's a problem and that
bring it together we're planning to do
so next year a major conference of
experiences in universal coverage in low
and middle income countries because it
is happening and people are grasping
with similar questions even though the
answers will be
different and there's a lot to be
learned by sharing and so we are
committed out to supporting that and to
supporting the policy community space to
do have a place where you go for this
because right now and I wasn't double
showing the health systems group and we
were thin there too there are budgeting
Alicia to with him in he clearly a space
where you can go on and get all of this
it will be a useful thing so we'll be
happy to follow up on that and for you
to share your experiences thank you very
much for your interesting talk on I mean
looking at the fact that health spending
is increasing is reassuring in a way but
when you begin to look at who is
benefiting from what I mean we've done
some benefit of incidence studies which
shows that the probably that top two
reaches quintiles are getting most of
the benefit and if you look at the
financing incidents as well and that
there are several distortions which
doesn't make it very progressive as we
desire for it to be I mean this this is
work that we're doing with South Africa
and Tanzania and I mean surprisingly
across all the three countries it's it's
very regressive but so yes health
spending is is is increasing but as far
as I health systems are concerned access
for the for the lowest to quintiles
still not we're still not getting there
and for me that is a bigger challenge
than the fact that how financing is is I
mean more money is being spent how do we
make it more equitable for me that's the
challenge Ryan I think they are actually
linked as the experience in Mexico shows
is there's the political dimension of
the country of of course and so they're
trying to redistribute resources it's
just a tough thing to do there's real
power and the systems and so on but if
instead you were simply where to invest
that future growth in can spending
in in the country as Mexico did then you
have an opportunity so it becomes an
opportunity for visionaries championing
with clever salesmanship really of not
taking away from the current people who
are getting money to invest the future
growth in health spending into equity
and quality and that is what the
opportunity of this economic transition
lays for us to be aware to educate our
our prime ministers is often not only
the minister of health is the president
or the Minister of Labour the minister
of finance and having this understanding
because important so again researching
this transition in your countries making
that evidence available to the key
decision-makers and positioning us in
the case of gana there's a recommitment
to increase insurance of course
universally and it's just you know stuff
to keep going and they will always have
to be some room for the politics that is
some people will be able to afford
things outside the system and but as we
said before there's no sinus system so
if some people spend a lot more even if
their own money the rich people they're
still eating into the pie of the health
spending for the country same thing
could be on medical tourism in Thailand
and so on and so I think that they would
have to be some room some accommodation
for that political pressure and how this
is done in every country well it will it
will depend on the politician leadership
of each country some countries are
simply committed to full equity right
and there are some who are doing quite
well there's Cuba doing quite well with
their financing model on the provision
model Thailand has been able to do it
with a great commitment to equity this
rule for some of the rich people go to
the private hospital so how much oh that
is ok as a compromise well those are
those are good questions
but it did not look at the also the
disease change over time especially
considering the emergence of new
diseases and in cost it will take to for
intervention then it also did not look
at efforts that I've been made also to
improve health care and provide equated
by investing resources to reach the very
poor take for instance immunization like
in my country for example to move from
about thirty five percent in a dbt three
coverage to about eighty-five percent
meant investing more and to be able to
reach very hard to reach areas and
providing services free and that brings
it back to the question that the Ghana
was the concern gonna had about reaching
the lower quartile with services yes and
I will agree fully with that we didn't
go into that but is fully agree with
that yes we like to say that yes there
will always be emerging diseases and
clearly AIDS is the elephant in the room
as to how things can happen and require
attention and priority and that is
something that can always happen in the
future is just that as a whole as a c4
as a whole the burden of disease is
declining in the world in and which is
good but husbanding is not going down
and that's the principle I want to
highlight equity agree and but you also
hinted a point of priorities relate to
both the global health initiatives and
the fact that governments may have
priorities priority priority setting is
a is a function of the health system
stewardship and so is a good thing to
the extent in fact aids treatment
programs we're addressing neglected
priorities and burden in countries
Australia good thing too and to the
extent that they after a disease that
can be eradicated is worth investment in
the long term
to the extent you bring best science
best practice and monitoring capacity
that also brings strengthening this was
a lot of good things that that some
priorities can do for health in the
context of a rational health system so
it should not be a discussion of such
approaches it says that each of those
approaches should be always recent
within the context of your larger health
enhancing and again for equity that
growth in health spending is in my mind
the best opportunity that we have in the
developing world to address the needs of